[Music]
the award-winning chef and owner of the
bakery milk bar is now also a children's
author christina tozie is out with a new
book every cake has a story does it okay
it aims to inspire kids and stretch
their imagination our meg oliver brought
her son cormic and his friends rishi
maddie and morgan to milk bar in new
york city to chat with tozie about the
book and to create the cake of their
dreams how about this you could make a
cake using the cinnamon roll as the cake
christina tosi still thinks of herself
as a creative kid i have a dream to make
a pancake
into a layer cake that i want to call
the pancake cake strike a pose she loves
to play and inspire young bakers to
dream of the yummiest toppings what are
you guys going to dream of strawberry i
can see the wheels turning maybe the
chocolate like the caramel that's my
girl she's the force behind a baking
empire from our famous milk bar stores
in new york city and beyond all over to
countless baking shows fake squad 60
seconds and the author of several
delicious cookbooks but just recently
the 39 year old cake and cookie queen
revealed her greatest creation a
six-month-old baby girl tosi's first
child that's probably my proudest title
to date yeah the proud mom to
six-month-old frankie is also the author
of a new children's book every cake has
a story it's about a little girl named
sammy who lives in a town that's stuck
in a rut but comes alive through the
creativity and baking sammy is like this
little girl she lives in samesville
everything is black and white everyone
eats the same meal every day wears the
same clothes everything is kind of just
the same
and
she yearns for more that is very much
the way that i felt when i was her age i
yearned for like more possibility and
more individuality and space for
creativity does samesville symbolize
part of your childhood
i think so a little bit i grew up in the
suburbs i loved going to the grocery
store that was like my thursday night
tour with my mom up and down the aisles
the cereal aisle are you kidding me the
baking aisle the different like
frostings and sprinkles and crumbs and
crunches like i thought of all the
different things that i could go home
and sort of like mash up in a little bit
of like a mad scientist way what was
your favorite part of the book when the
color showed up when the color showed up
why it was weird reading in black and
white it was much more alive much more
alive much like everything was much more
creative everyone was
would you ever want to live and sing
still
no
what's the message you want kids to take
away from this book
the message i want kids to take away
from every cake has a story is that
life is to be lived on your terms
yeah
that you are the first and only you and
that is the most powerful thing that you
could ever have in this world you have
it
now it's just a matter of doing
something
positive and productive with it in the
world that is the secret to life
how's this yeah
there we go
a secret she wants to spread far and
wide
so much
oh that's cool that's a great story for
the kids to go to meg i love what
christina said life is to be lived on
your terms he does great cakes too